[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jacob is
in Fort Worth Texas hi Jacob how are
you doing well sir how you doing better
than I deserve what's
up hey I was just calling because uh
obviously I I enjoy listening to you and
U respect your opinion my fiance and I
we're looking to move from Fort Worth
back to our home state of Minnesota cool
and so I was looking to get your opinion
about kind of what to look for when
buying our first home and um looking at
like a a fix upper versus a house that's
already at like Prestige shape U maybe
in a growing Market our idea is that
we're not going to be here forever or in
that home so we're looking to grow
Equity um in the smartest way possible
fiance did you say
fiance yes sir yeah my fiance and I yeah
when are you getting
married um well we keep pushing it off
we've been engaged for about two years
but we uh originally from Minnesota we
moved down to Kansas City for two years
and then we moved to Fort Worth kind of
on a whim and then decided so we're
hoping to get married at the end of next
year but our goal is to buy a home first
don't do not buy a home with someone
you're not married
to you're going to get yourself into
legal relational spiritual and financial
trouble don't do it don't do it I talked
to a g a gal yesterday that called me
she had been living with a guy for 8
years they had two cars in their names
four credit cards in their names and a
house in their names and he
left you know what she is
screwed she can't get she can't sell any
of it cuz he won't sign the titles to
any of it he won't pay the payments on
any of it so she's being forced into
bankruptcy because of this right here
don't do this go to see the preacher and
get your butt married before you buy a
house okay because you're going to get
in a mess dude you're GNA get in a
serious mess don't do that I've been
doing this 30 years all I've heard is
pain around this subject no one ever
gets blessed by what you're trying to do
here don't do it please don't do it now
once you get up there and you're married
because you're going to go get married
this weekend now that her y'all been
together two years so I'm like just get
the license you guys are married you're
acting like you're married you're
basically married yeah painter get off
the ladder you got this jacob I believe
in you I debated about that um you know
part of it was going to get our license
like you like you just said and then all
the other part of me was thinking about
like it was her special day so I kind of
wanted everything to happen at once yeah
but her goal is to this is our biggest
investment and we're not looking to you
know a lot of people take out loans and
they have these fancy weddings that cost
so much money but that's not really what
we're looking for um for the long game
but it is still her special day yeah it
is her special day so don't screw it up
with buying a house before the special
day and then y'all have no special
days definitely definitely so you
recommend um you know like just going to
get a simple license or I don't care I
mean y'all figure it out figure out what
what the point is that what special day
looks like but I would not put your name
on a deed with someone that you are not
married to you're creating what your
attorney would tell you is called a
general partnership with no general
partnership
documents and so I and I've seen all
kinds of horrible things happen to
people in these situations some of them
are just mean some of them are sad but
it just it's a mess one guy his fiance
got killed now and there was no will she
got killed in a car wreck and now he
owns a house with her
mother talk about awward yeah talk about
awkward that's a mess so don't do that
no okay now so y'all figure out how
whether you know how you're going to get
married but before you're Mar before you
buy a house together get married now
let's pretend you're married and then
we'll answer your question if you're
brand new married I would not buy a
fixer upper fixer ERS are hard work it's
tough it's distracting I would want you
to focus on each other and be in love
instead of hanging curtains and and
peeling old old wallpaper off because
say this it it's s it's romanticized on
HGTV it it feels like oh my gosh we're
going to fix this house up and get what
we want all of it and it does end up
being usually more expensive the time
frame is longer you're dealing with
contractors you're trying to I mean you
it's a second job is basically what that
is and so for your first year of
marriage you live in dust Perpetual dust
it's dust it's not ex people do it well
but it sounds a whole lot better than
the actual reality of it there there
there's nothing good about it renovated
one house while I lived in it it's a
disas I'm sitting in a lawn chair on
plywood floors cuz everything's ripped
up watching the Super Bowl one time I
told Sharon I said you might be a
redneck if you're sitting in your own
house inside in a lawn chair on a
plywood floor watching the Super Bowl
that's what renovating a house is it
ain't chip and Joanna I'm just telling
you nobody's hair is done the makeup's
not right it's all bad okay there's no
reality in reality TV GTV has ruined
your perception of this thing so no I
would not do a fixer upper not my first
house if you're going to do a fixer
upper don't live in it while you're
doing it live somewhere else fix it up
over there then move in it if you want
to do a if you want to get a some Equity
from some work being done it can be a
little little bit of light work like
we've got to do we got to tear all the
Landscaping out we got to run a coat of
paint through the thing that's okay but
this idea we're going to knock down
walls and and you know The Decorator is
going to prance through through and tell
you no no and the kitchens no you're
killing me no don't please expectation
though may have to lower that depending
on what you guys can afford you know
that won't be this topof the line either
though right so like there's a there's a
a medium there of like yeah but that's a
good point I I forget that These reality
shows that aren't reality that have
nothing to do with they're scripted as
they can be um and the hilarious thing
is people in the industry call them
unscripted TV but they're about they're
more scripted than a dadgum sitcom and
then and they've romanticize it make
make you know between commercial breaks
the whole thing gets
done and and it no it's eight months
later and you're still sucking drywall
dust while you're trying to sleep you
know it's just it's nasty I grew up in
the construction business I've done
probably, 1500 rehabs in my life I used
to do it for a living you don't want to
do that it's not it's not what TV
portrays it to be you're right about
that I had thought had not thought about
that part of the problem sounds dreamy
and romantic yeah it's not it's not fun
yeah um I I I know it's shocking to you
people but those people on The Bachelor
could have got a date without the TV
show it's shocking I know but um yeah
it's it's if they were really looking to
not be a bachelor he probably could have
worked it out but um so without any
anyway so yeah that that's funny
Rachel's favorite show is that your
favorite show still uh it's moved on to
the Real Housewives real house we can
talk reality TV another day Dave you
will not like my reality TV I don't like
any reality TV and the Kardashians new
Season's out you know I love it I think
it's all fantastic you are so culturally
relevant I think I that I am that I am
you kept mentioning Tiger King even like
six months ago I was like oh Dave no one
watches that anymore no I mean was thing
that was a thing during the fouchy
pandemic did fouy pmic we watched Tiger
King yeah but love is blind talks a lot
about money there's a lot of
conversations around it none of it makes
sense yeah all right there we go you
never know uh good luck Jacob I hope it
works out for you my brother uh sorry
you called in and got a speech but I
don't want I don't want bad things for
you I love you I want you to Wi you see
how I feel growing up yeah that's what
Rachel got at the room still in
counseling for it this is the Ramsey
Show